the European Union's General Affairs
Council is due to set this week a date
for Serbia to start at CU membership
negotiations the minister's must choose
a day that falls before the end of
January to launch the process which will
see Serbia negotiate the 35 policy areas
or chapters candidates must complete
before they can join they'll also assess
Albania's request for candidate status
and the former Republic of Macedonia
hopes of beginning accession talks as
part of a broader look at the EU
enlargement process the council is also
set to debate a review of the European
external action service talks will focus
on some recommendations that could be
implemented in the short term notably
boosting cooperation between EU
delegations and those of the Member
States and improving the effectiveness
of common security and defence policy
missions The ministers will also discuss
preparations for the European Council on
the nineteenth and twentieth of December
in Brussels EU leaders are set to
discuss defence policy and Europe's
defence industry economic policy and
progress on completing the banking Union
the fate of would-be immigrants in the
Mediterranean and relations with Ukraine
and the Central African Republic